when you wrote the song my way for frank
sinatra yeah he should have blown you
i mean that was something that was a
great that was low on my list of what i
wanted from brexit
i did it my way but you you read that
you you saw him and you just you were
inspired to write that was he the
inspiration
he was he'd always joke with me about
writing for him i wasn't going to give
him lonely boy and all that [ __ ]
right
so so my friend don costa introduced him
he became his producer
so we're down in miami he's doing a
movie he calls me up he says kid come on
have dinner i go and have dinner with
him this is like 67.
he said i'm quitting i've had it you
know because you go in this room with
them there were holes all over the wall
because they were bugging them so you
have
one guy on salary just putting new
phones in why were they bugging them
because the mob stuff
guys so he said look i've had it i'm
quitting blah blah blah so this
really moved me because i said sinatra
leaving ding ding
came back to new york where i was living
one o'clock in the morning i started
writing
as if frank sinatra were writing the
lyrics so i started metaphorically with
the now the end is near final curtain
i finish it i called how long does that
take you to finish five hours
five hours you wrote the entire song my
way yeah music came first or the lyrics
well i had the music it was a french
melody
i just changed and changed the whole
vibe to it
recreated the song and you said hey i
fly out to vegas
i give him the demo record i said frank
here for your last album
he listened to it i knew they liked it
two months later i got a call
he's in a studio puts the phone up says
kid listen to this and they play me my
way
for the first time i started crying it
was kind of a turning point you know for
me as a writer growing up
all of that so i had no regrets about
giving it away because he was the only
guy to do it
how old were you when you wrote that my
late 20s no kidding
that's a pretty sophisticated song right
for an old guy yeah
so when sinatra when sinatra records his
thing and he holds it up on the phone so
you can hear it yeah
you start to cry you're like oh my god
this is great do you know right away
this is going to be
not only a hit but a signature you know
it's special
how are you none of us in the business
you know there's a few times when you
really
sense a smash right you know you know it
you know it but
there's a lot of times where you do
something professionally and you just
don't know it but that was one of the
times where i knew it was something how
long before you wrote that thing and all
of a sudden now is a song on the radio
it's pretty instantaneous
uh probably about two three months later
two three months later and then it
becomes like a number one song and he
decides not to retire anymore right so
then i wrote the second song let me try
again
let me try again he came back
you